all right let's go through this quickly
by the way i forgot when i drew up my
axes you should always
put the origin put the y and the x okay
always first thing you did before you
put anything all right let's have a go
now i'm going to do this a bit quicker
i'm not going to do it as slowly as i
did here because this is the first go
i'm going to do this kind of speed
version all right so
i look at this right and i'm comparing
it to this
right so i notice there's
the gradient m m is right in front of
the x
and they're including the minus
you clear the minus there's the y
intercept the b
okay so then i'm going to say i'll start
with the y intercept i go down to -2
here's the y-axis here so i go one
two there's negative two i did it this
way there's negative two okay
so y-intercept right what is it then
what do i do i've done the y-intercept
now i go
to the gradient i can see there's rise
right it's rise over run
okay so three and four rise i've got to
go up
three units so i go one
two so i should have put an x there one
two
three there we go okay
now if that's three units what number am
i gonna be at one
very good excellent
what do i do with the four well rise
means go up right means go across
right so i'm gonna go uh one two
three four i'm gonna go across to
there bingo okay which is go across
four okay i went up three
went across four and now here's my point
okay
last step join them up all right
to as long as we're all ready
you keep going just quietly okay now
here's what i'm gonna do so that i can
show you another example very quickly
i'm gonna cheat a little bit and just
modify this one just gonna modify this
one
i'm gonna modify it in a tricky way okay
so watch with me
what if i consider this
now i'll show you i'll show you what to
do with this it's not hard
when you're ready now watch we'll do the
same thing again i'm looking for
m and b there's m
notice he includes a minus sign and then
there's b
okay now since this b and this b are
still the same right same as the
original question
i've still got that same y-intercept
which is great that's really good okay
but but my gradient
something's gone a bit wacky let me
write this out again on its own so you
can see what's happening
bless you minus three over four okay so
the rise
is negative the rise is negative that
means it's not going up
it's going it's going down
now watch watch what's going to happen
our rise is negative but the 4 is still
still positive okay so here's the way
i'm going to do it
um instead of going up three units
that's what happened here i'm gonna go
down
so from minus two negative two i should
say
if i go down three i go negative three
negative four negative five
okay there you go now i went down three
and then i go across four again so i'm
still going to line up with here
it'll be something like that
okay so you can see i might draw it in
again there's the rise which is
negative so it goes down and there's the
run which was the same as before
all right yes it's not really right at
all okay but now i've got my two points
i can join them up just like i did
before
it'll look uh sorry wrong color it'll
look like this
yeah it's exactly right it'll go the
other way
okay so it's kind of like that one but
upside down
so what's the same the y
intercept is the same the negative two
what's changed
it rise the the gradient the rise has
gone down instead of up
right so that's why he's going forward
off the side
okay so you can see what happens right
we had a positive x a y intercept here
so it's above
you've got a negative one here so it's
below and then you pay careful attention
to which way the gradient's going is
that all right